[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens publ débat
reportage chronique et analyse comme
tous les jours du lundi au jeudi à 18h
et 22h sur Public Sénat et voici le
sommaire de ce 26 septembre c'est quoi
l'écologie à la française nouvelle
boussole de la planification vantée par
Emmanuel Macron les mesures annoncées
par le chef de l'État plus 1 citative
moins sacrificiell sont-elles à la
hauteur de l'urgence climatique ce sera
l'un des thèmes de notre débat d'actu
politique où l'on décortiquera également
le baromètre odoxa de septembre rentré
plutôt sereine pour l'exécutif avec un
ministre qui confirme sa percé dans
l'opinion Gabriel hatal et puis pour
notre second débat volontairement décalé
de l'acte du jour débat de société on
plonge au cœur de la crise de
l'immobilier aujourd'hui onarrive plus à
loger les gens il faut plus ans pour
avoir un logement social à Paris comment
c'est possible comment en est-on arrivé
là logement social immobilier locatif
accès à la propriété construction de
bâtiments neufs c'est tout le secteur
qui souffre est-ce la pire crise de son
histoire réponse de nos experts dans
trois quart d'heure mais d'abord donc le
détail du baromètre odoxa mascaré pour
Public Sénat et la presse quotidienne
régionale avec
cécileou pour succéder à Emmanuel Macron
en 2027 les Français choisissent Édouard
Philippe 50 % d'entre eux pensent qu'il
ferait un bon candidat même si pour le
moment l'intéressé estime qu'il est
encore trop tôt pour penser à la
présidentielle de 2027 notre horizon ça
n'est pas celui d'une simple élection
fut-elle la plus prestigieuse ou la plus
importante notre horizon ça n'est pas un
horizon tactique omnubilé par la
perspective d'une bataille électorale
c'est au contraire de construire un
mouvement et une stratégie qui qui
permettent de mettre en œuvre
durablement la politique nécessaire au
pays loin derrière lui le ministre de
l'éducation nationale Gabriel Atal est
considéré par 29 % des Français comme le
deuxème meilleur candidat sa rentrée
très médiatique a fait exploser sa côte
de popularité elle augmente de 11 points
pour atteindre 32 % il reste tout de
même classé derrière Marine Le Pen et
éedouard Philippe ellisabeth borne aussi
profite d'une légère progression dans sa
côte de popular
avec TR points supplémentaires elle
rassemble 31 % d'opinion favorable
Emmanuel Macron en revanche se stabilise
il est considéré comme un bon président
pour 32 % des Français mais le sondage
réalisé la semaine dernière n'intègre
pas l'intense semaine diplomatique du
président avec la visite du roi Charles
I et le passage du pape à Marseille en
détail les résultat de notre baromètre
de septembre et évidemment on analyse
aussi l'actu politique du jour avec
Céline bra bonsoir bienvenue bonsoir
Thomas directrice générale d'odoxa ya Go
bonsoir et bienvenue éditorialiste chef
du service politique de France interre
Bastien François bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi vous êtes professeur de
sciences politiques à l'Université Paris
1 Panthéon Sorbonne j'accueille
également Émilie zapalski bonsoir Émilie
spécialiste en communication politique
éditorialiste pour sens public on va
commencer par cette course à la
succession d'Emmanuel Macron je vous
entend dire mais c'est beaucoup trop tôt
la présidentielle c'est dans 3 ans mais
c'est quand même intéressant de de
prendre cette photographie voilà
aujourd'hui en temps réel dans ce climat
particulier d'équilibre politique
particulier réponse des des personnes
interrogées par le baromètre au doxa
mascaré elle a déjà commencé pour 83 %
des Français gens ne disent pas non
c'estopt c'est une braque qui sont les
mieux placés aujourd'hui dans l'esprit
des des Français pour succéder à
Emmanuel Macron alors disons qu'il y a
pour le moment on va dire un favori un
super challenger un challenger et puis
après un groupe on va dire le le Ploton
est un peu
un peu distancé alors le grand favori
pour le moment c'est Édouard Philippe
puisque quand on pose la question sur
qui est
le alors d'abord sur la question de
candidat qui est le meilleur candidat
pour la présidentielle c'est lui qui est
cité très largement on a 50 % des
Français qui qui le citent et puis en
plus on on le voit depuis des mois il
est extrêmement populaire il est très
peu impopulaire c'estàd que c'est la
personnalité politique qui est la la
moins rejeté de de toutes les
personnalités politiques conteste donc
lui c'est vraiment le favori derrière il
y a un petit nouveau là qui se glisse
qui est Gabriel Atal c'estàdire que lui
en terme de candidat à la présidentielle
il est il est un peu loin derrière il
est 29 %ou mais en code d'adhésion on
l'a vu dans le sujet il progresse il
fait un bon de 11 points et c'est énorme
parce que sur le baromètre politique
c'est très très rare d'avoir une
personnalité politique qui en quelques
mois progresse aussi vite donc vraiment
on va dire que lui est derrière et qu'il
est pas très impopulaire pour un
ministre donc lui c'est le super
challenger après il y a un challenger
qui est Bruno Le Maire qui est vu à peu
près autant comme un bon candidat 28 %
mais il est un peu derrière en terme de
popularité il est un peu plus rejeté il
est il est moins consensuel aussi et
puis derrière les poursuivants ça va
être les les deux premier ministres
ex-Premier ministre qu'on a testé à
savoir ellisabeth borne et Jean Castex
alors d'abord ils sont beaucoup moins
vus comme des PO candidat même s'ils ont
des codes de popularité qui sont pas
loin des autres mais on les voit
beaucoup moins comme des candidats et
c'est le cas aussi d'Olivier verr qui
n'est pas qui n'a pas cette comment dire
dimension auux français en tout cas pour
l'instant mais comme les sur on est pas
très romantiqueamour ne r pas toujours
avec toujours et que Damours ne RIM pas
toujours pas non plus avec toujours ça
veut dire que ça peut ça peut bouger
évidemment ça peut bouger comme on l'a
dit il y a du temps est-ce qu'on peut
dire que Gabriel fait un S fa depuis son
arrivée Rud Grenel au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale on peut dire que
Gabriel Atal c'est un petit peu le la la
fusée la fusée de cette rentrée et il a
bénéficié on aurait pu penser que
c'était un obstacle quand Emmanuel
Macron a dit que le domaine régalien ce
sera à lui maintenant domaine réservé
l'éducation l'école en réalité c'est
presque un un carburant pour Gabriel
Atal parce que tout ce qu'il fait se
fait avec l'assentiment du grand chef
Emmanuel Macron qui lui a dit c'est mon
domaine réservé donc s'il a un exécutant
qui fait exactement la feuille de route
pour laquelle il a été nommé euh c'est
parfait ça veut dire interdiction des
abayas validé à l'Élysée et cetera et sû
cette stratégie là le Conseil d'État
deux fois donne raison au ministre sur
l'interdiction de de ce vêtement dans
les établissements scolaires hier il
était au rectorat de Versailles pour
continuer à agir sur le harcèlement
scolaire avec un plan qui sera présenté
demain pour dire qu'il faut absolument
que le rectorat de Versailles et plus
largement tout les recteurs de France ne
prennent plus à la légère les alertes
quand il y a des parents qui qui se
plaignent donc quelque part il est
rentré dans une dans la lumière de
manière assez fulgurante c'est très
efficace quand on regarde son parcours
c'est assez fou parce que moi quand je
en 2012 Quand je suivais la au service
politique de à l'époque c'était RTL je
me retrouvais parfois avec Marie
soltouren sur des déplacements il y
avait un un un petit conseiller dans
l'ombre qui avait été son stagiaire à
l'Assemblée quand elle était député
c'est Gabriel Atal oui 2012 203 ça va
vite qui aurait imaginé cette cette
ascension alors après attention
ascension oui on est dans le premier
mois
h 3000 prof oui alors c'est ce que
j'allais demander à B fris est-ce que
finalement les questions de fond les
effectifs l'état des établissements
scolaires leur équipement est-ce que ces
questionsl pour l'instant elles sont
gommées par par voilà la par les
effectivement le harcèlement mais elles
vont finir par arriver le plus dur
commence en quelque sorte moi j'ai
l'impression qu'elles sont gommées un
peu exprès par par la façon dont on été
construite alors je suis pas dans la
tête du ministre et ni dans ses calculs
mais ça tombait quand même vraiment
extrêmement bien cette histoire d'abaya
pour qu'on parle de ça que tout le monde
parle de ça qu'on ne parle plus que de
ça alors que la situation quand même à
l'école est très difficile enfin dans
l'éducation nationale de façon plus
large que l'école très difficile que le
Président de la République avait quand
même promis un prof dans chaque classe
et ce n'est pas le
cas et ce qui vaut d'ailleurs pour
l'école vaut pour d'autres services
publics bon donc effectivement c'est
peut-être un petit peu tôt hein il a du
talent on le savait il a un talent
gigantesque il avait un grand talent
quand il s'occupait des comptes publics
où il trouvait chaque fois des petites
niches pour exister à côté de de de son
ministre il a eu du talent au moment de
la discussion des retraites parce qu'il
était à l'Assemblée très souvent et il
était un des ministres quand même qui
prenait la parole et qui prenait et qui
aller au charbon hein dans un moment
très difficile bon donc c'est pas c'est
c'est c'est un c'est un c'est un jeune
ministre qui a beaucoup de talent bon
bon il va falloir voir il y a encore
quelques années et c'est c'est un
dossier extrêmement difficile
l'éducation nationale éidemment un mot
rapide oui moi ce qui m'intéresse aussi
c'est ce que ça va donner comme
inflexion sur le en même temps et sur le
macronisme en fait la personnalité qu' y
aura derrière parce que comme vous
l'avez dit finalement Gabriel Atal c'est
le dauphin merveilleux c'est le meilleur
dauphin qui suivra qui est pilepoil
aligné avec cette espèce de en même
temps qui repose principalement sur les
épaules d'Emmanuel Macron si c'est un
éedouard Philippe on est encore plus à
droite qu'à l'heure actuelle hein c'est
c'est c'est l'âge pivot c'est les 67 ans
c'est la dette c'est des choses beaucoup
plus à droite et Bruno Le Maire encore
un peu différent donc c'est c'est cette
espè de de choses qu'on comprend pas
encore très bien le en même temps qui va
changer d'axe en fonction de qui prendra
la suite et ça ça va être très
intéressant Gabriel Attal est vraiment
en ligne il me semble avec ce qu'a
souhaité Emmanuel Macron et notamment
sur cette partie communication don vous
avez dit c'est-à-dire on affiche
beaucoup de choses parce que on veut
qu'au niveau marketing c'est un peu une
politique marketing on veut afficher des
choses et parfois on veut un petit peu
cacher le fond et et avancer un peu
masqué sur les sujets avec quand même
une difficulté qui vaut pour lui et pour
tous les autres les succès suesseur
potentiel il bien un momentù il va
falloir qu'il se démarque d'El Macron et
de son bilan je voudrais qu'on se tourne
vers Yv San qui est seigneur partenire
chez mascaré donc qui est notre
partenaire également sur ce baromètre
vous scrutez les les réseaux sociaux les
médias sociaux tous les mois pour pour
nous est-ce que enfin on va on va
peut-être élargir un peu sur les
personnalités les plus
mentionnées toute famille politique
confondu he pas seulement les les
papabil pas seulement les successeurs
potentiels est-ce que Gabriel Atal en
fait partie là depuis un
mois alors depuis un mois non mais
depuis la depuis la rentrée oui je sais
pas si vous vous si on revient un petit
peu en arrière sur sur cette année et
c'est pas une intéressant de le faire on
a eu un premier semestre qui était
extrêmement politique avec la question
des retraites la question de les fameux
débats sur les les déficits
démocratiques le on avait ensuite noté
une sorte de repli de l'intérêt très
très fort de l'intérêt pour le
politique avec que probablement euh euh
une sorte d'impuissance des oppositions
à agir sur le cours des choses euh la
rentrée elle se fait sur des sujets
qu'on a qualifié des sujets de très
polémiques et très controversés vous
l'avez vu vous l'avez vous avez évoqué
mais si on note les très forts pics de
mention associés aux personnalités
Gabriel aalent fait partie euh ce sont
les controverses sur la baaya ce sont
les sifflés au moment de la coupe de de
rugby sur le président de la République
c'est évidemment euh en pedusa euh ils
ont une particularité dans leur forme
médiatique c'est que ce sont des sujets
qui connaissent des très forts pics de
mention ça explique pas mal de choses
pour pour Gabriel Atal 9 millions de
mentions en un lapse de temps très court
une semaine et après ils retombent ce
sont des sujets qui retombent ils on une
deuxième particularité ces sujets c'est
qu'ils ne sont pas liés avec la vie
législative donc ils sont un peu en
l'air sur la question dans la question
politique la question ce sera de savoir
quelle sera leur pérennité en tout cas
les sujets en eux-même qui ont été
extrêmement portés qu'il s'agisse de de
la controverse entre Édouard Philippe et
Fabien Roussel on l'avait noté qui a
fait énormément de bruit sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'il s'agit des interventions
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou de Marine Le
Pen relativement à à la question de
Lampedusa ou les autres sujets qu'on
vient de citer il y a il y a aussi le le
le sujet du ch mdine par exemple alors
on va pas faire toute la liste he pardon
de vous interrompre sens mais ce que je
retiens c'est que vraiment c'est un peu
le fonctionnement des médias sociaux
hein des réseaux sociaux c'est que les
les polémiques entraînent derrière elle
les personnalités qui sont liées c'est
une BR qu'on va élargir continuer
élargir en regardant le le palmarès de
l'adhésion donc là on n'est pas
seulement sur les successeurs de d'El
Macron on est bien d'accord le les
personnalités politiques préférées des
des Français là aussi on a un Édouard
Philippe toujours en tête oui toujours
en tête et qui reprend un peu de de d'an
puisque aujourd'hui il a 40 % d'adhésion
plus 4 points alors que c'est vrai que
la période de de des discussions sur les
retraites il enempathtissait lui aussi
donc là voilà il disons qu' ilfin il
progresse encore et sont c'est vraiment
le grand favori dans ce dans ce palmarès
ensuite on a marine Le Pen euh Gabriel
Atal entre deux et Jordane bardellaa
pour les deux personnalités du
rassemblement national on peut remarquer
qu'il prennent chacun des points plus tr
points pour Marine Le Pen plus 5 points
pour Jordane Bardella et les sujets on
va pas y revenir qu'on a évoqué ici sont
des sujets qui sont très porteurs pour
le rassemblement national donc on voit
que dans l'opinion c'est ça qui marche
bien et puis enfin 5e personnalité Bruno
Le Maire 26 % qui lui aussi on verra
bien siil est candidat un jour peut-être
à la
présidentielle est un comment dire une
personnalité qui est toujours très haut
dans notre dans notre code d'adhésion et
pas trop rejeté lui non plus comme
Gabriel Attal c'est une autre part ou
parceil y a toujours la code d'adhésion
et la code de rejet par exemple Marine
Le Pen on peut en dire un mot code
d'adhésion qui quand Mme importante
deuxième personnalité politique he
préférée des des Français sa côte de
rejet est-ce qu'elle se réduit quand
même aussi parce que ça c'est une
dimension intéressante de la perception
par l'opinion publique de la
normalisation on va dire du
rassemblement national et de et de
Marine Le Pen ouis bah Mar Marine Le Pen
elle fait toujours partie des
personnalités
rejeté mais vous voyez aujourd'hui elle
est 5e pendant longtemps elle a été
personnalité la plus rejetée très très
loin devant tout le monde maintenant
c'est Eric Zemour et et vous avez raison
c'est-à-dire que même sur le sur le le
rejet elle perd du terrain sur le rejet
donc elle gagne vraiment du terrain des
des deux côtés elle est moins rejeté
parce qu'il y a du parce qu'il y a du
carburant en ce moment pour pour pour le
vote Ren tous les sujets mènent à Marine
Le Pen et à le Yaca faucon puisque vous
avez évidemment inflation vous avez
l'ampetousa qui crée une peur migratoire
euh jusqu'à l'irrationnel dans dans dans
son discours vous avez l'écologie
punitive qui fait peur aussi voilà tout
tout tout mène quelque part à au au au
grand au grand viv idéologique du du RN
qui surf sur les peurs moi ce que
j'aimerais mesurer un jour je sais pas
si on pourra c'est à quel point la crise
de l'OM et tout ça si on rentre dans les
détails créer un biais au RN puisqu'on a
vu une dirigeante d'extrême droite
première ministre en Italie euh qui
avait promis euh le le zéro immigration
et qui se retrouve à appeler l'Europe au
secours blocus naval SOS Bruxelles ce
qui est complètement en porte à fau avec
la la campagne il y a plus d'un an
maintenant de mélonie et Marine Le Pen
dit moi j'aurais pas fait comme ça mais
corct elle fait il y a le virtuel d'un
côté et une dirigeante dans la réalité
de l'autre issue d'un bord politique
proche même si c'est pas le RN et que et
que son ami
c'estit par détail et là je pense qu'il
y a pour elle c'est une rentrée qui est
pas aussi simple qu' n par et ça sera
évidemment très intéressant à suivre
dans les prochaines semaines dans les
prochains mois et puis même dans les
dans les années qui nous mènent à la à
la présidentielle parce que le costume
de favorite est pas forcément le plus
facile àter voilà il faut pas l'avoir
Trô c'est aussi le cas d'édard Philippe
et on va continuer de se concentrer sur
la stratégie d'Édouard Philippe je
propose à audre betaz de nous rejoindre
tout de suite puisqueon va regarder
encore un peu les les résultats des
sénatorials bonsoir Audrey qui son qui
sont très intéressant à analyser on
marque que le parti horizon d'Édouard
Philippe Tiss petit à petit sa toile oui
grand bouleversement dimanche au Sénat
les les équilibres restent en place mais
quand on regarde les changements dans la
marge à la marche pardon c'est là que ça
devient intéressant on remarque
notamment que le groupe Les Indépendants
a gagné des sièges il passe de 14 sièges
à environ 19 pourquoi environ 19 parce
que les chiffres doivent encore être
consolidé il y a encore des transfuges
en ce moment et bien ce groupe qui est
présidé par Claude maluré un fidèle
d'Édouard Philippe c'est dans ce groupe
que siègent les sénateurs horizon alors
attention tous les indépendants ne sont
pas encartés horizon mais d'après Claude
maluret ils ont tous au moins de la
sympathie pour Édouard Philippe son aura
a donc progressé au Sénat Thomas les
philippistes si je dire progressent
quand le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle lui est plutôt en train
de régresser oui les macronistes au
Sénat pourraient être entre TR et qu de
moins après comptage il pâtissse d'un
manque d'encrache local du parti
présidentiel à l'inverse pour Claude
maluret Horizon a réussi le test des
sénatoriales il estime que la stratégie
d'implantation territoriale du tout
jeune parti a fonctionné souvenez-vous
au moment de sa création horizon avit
décidé de s'appuyer sur les élus locaux
sur les maires surtout au centre de son
organisation comme pour se démarquer
d'Emmanuel Macron a écouté le constat
que faisait Claude muré c'était dimanche
soir c'est une victoire de la stratégie
de construction du parti d'eddouard
Philippe c'est une construction
progressive c'est une construction qui
s'appuie sur les territoires et même sur
les communes beaucoup plus que sur les
départements ou les circonscriptions ce
qui en fait un parti très très à part et
visiblement cette stratégie elle est
payante alors il faut tout de même même
nuancer cette affirmation le vrai test
pour vérifier l'ancrage local ce sera
les municipales de 2026 car pour
l'instant les sénateurs horizon ont été
élu par des maires transfuges on pense
par exemple à Arnaud Robinet le maire de
reins qui était LR qui est passé chez
Horizon et donc qui a permis l'élection
d'un sénateur horizon dans la Marne à
faire à suivre donc Thomas sur le long
terme merci beaucoup audre bet
effectivement sur cette question de la
la percée des des sénateurs horizon
Bastien François est-ce que vous dites
percée relative
oui pers relative mais comme l'expliquer
les sédentorial enregistre un résultat
d' y a 3 ans bon avec des petites
petites variations mais quand même hein
c'est les élections c'est les élections
municipales de 2020 qui qui dessinent
les sénateor les les résultats des
sénatorial bien très largement donc en
fait
euh le Sénat
n'enregistre les mouvements politiques
avec chaque fois un petit décalage et
les prochaines sénatorial le prochain
renouvellement du Sénat après les
prochaines municipales et bien là à mon
avis on verra quelque chose ça montre
aussi peut-être même si c'est que un
petit un signal faible comme on dit
quand même petite revanche quand même ou
le début de la revanche de l'ancien
monde hein c'està qu'il y avait une
stratégie celle d'Édouard Philippe qui
était une stratégie extrêmement
classique on construit un nouveau parti
et comment on le construit en allant
chercher des élus locaux voilà hein
c'est bon en en travaillant de cette
façonl par le haut sur l'encrage
territoriale et on a par rapport à la
stratégie
du macroniste qui n'a jamais réussi
peut-être même n'a jamais voulu
construire un vrai parti avec une vraie
implantation territorial avec des élus
locaux sans oublier le fait que
Emmanuel Macron a toujours eu un
discours assez distant vis-à-vis des
territoires et des élus locaux et des
corps intermédiaires on effectivement
dire çag ça fait quand même 6 ans plus
de 6 ans qu'émanuel Macron a été élu
pour la première fois pourquoi pourquoi
il y a pas eu cet effort
d'implantation territoriale est patant
c'est ça que c'est c'est cette photolà
que donne euh le Sénat depuis dimanche
voilà voilà le résultat d'une
implantation locale ratée de la part de
renaissance et précédemment de la
République en marche si on extrapole
pour la présidentielle c'est intéressant
ce yatus Renaissance qui baisse et
horizon qui monte parce qu'il y a deux
chemins possibles pour succéder Emmanuel
Macron vous avez un chemin de succession
au sein même de renaissance et vous avez
dans le parti Renaissance plusieurs
prétendants qui ont choisi ce cheminl
Gérald daranin Bruno leemire Gabriel
Atal et puis vous avez le chemin en solo
d'échappé belle d'Édouard Philippe qui
fait du Chirac 76 quand Chirac crée le
RPR et sort de Matignon pour créer c'est
cette stratégie là que choisit Édouard
Philippe c'està-dire libre mais loyal
mais très libre et en fait tellement
libre qu'il a sa pro son propre écue
qu'il dépend de personne à part de son
propre parti qu'il a créé c'est moins
frontal quand même que 67 76
shirac mais à un moment donné la
question se posera c'est est-ce qu'
comment il font à Renaissance il font
une primaire entre eux Ouard Philippe
est tranquille dans son chemin dans son
couloirf ça va c'est quelque chose qui
va au vu des chiffres que l'on a vu ce
soir de code d'adhésion et cetera à un
moment donné va se poser la question de
comment vous vous départagez primaire
des sondages ou prima à nouveau es ont
plus la côte mais non les primaires pas
mal de partis
politiques c'est un petit thermomètre de
plus de des deux chemin qui s'éloig
allez on parle de la de la gauche et de
la stratégie de la gauche avec ou sans
LFI nup ou
nupes et et on regarde effectivement de
nouveau le baromètre d'X ça mascaré pour
Public Sénat et nos confrères de la
presse quotidienne régionale si on
regarde les personnalités de gauche la
première en 8e position c'est Fabien
Roussel ensuite on a Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui est 14e juste derrière François
Ruffin bon et et si on regarde le le le
match entre guillemets Fabien Roussel
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça donne quoi bah oui
ça donne que en ce moment en tout cas on
voit vraiment que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
perd beaucoup de terrain h c'est-à-dire
qu'il arrive plus à accrocher des points
supplémentaires là on le voit il perd
trois points il est très rejeté c'est la
deuxième personnalité la plus rejetée
derrière Eric Zemour donc quand on fait
le le si le le 58 % de rejet seulement
19 % d'adhésion donc vraiment on
l'entend un peu on l'a entendu là sur
sur sur les migrants mais ça l'accroche
plus du tout avec avec les sympathisants
de gauche alors que Fabien Roussell
alors là aussi c'est peut-être un ça il
faut faut suivre ça dans le temps ça
peut être un épiphénomène là on voit
qu'il est à 25 % donc il est bien plus
haut dans notre dans notre classement il
est 8e il gagne lui du terrain et euh le
petit jeu le petit duel qui a eu avec
éedouard Philippe justement euh à la à
la fête de l'UMA ça a bien marché
c'estàd on a voilà il sens disait sur
les réseaux sociaux ça a bien cartonné
mais ça marche pas mal parce c'est un
peu alors je sais pas ça va durer la
personnalité de gauche préféré les
électeurs de droite Fabien r Je dire
pour un communiste c'est étonnant mais
c'est il gagne il gagne vraiment des
points à gauche d'ailleurs c'est
l'avantage quand même de ce genre de
duel avec Édouard Philippe parce que ça
le place à un niveau euh voyez de de de
pourquoi pas de de voilà de
présidentiable de face à un ex- Premier
ministre dans une position un peu grand
seigneur aussi je reçois un opposant de
droite je demande au au sympathisants
qui sont là de se calmer de la voilà
d'être respectueux donc ça dans dans les
deux camps pour Édouard Philippe comme
pour Fabien Roussel ça marche c'était
gagnant gagnant Émilie on a l'impression
c'est c'est un peu un concours là ça
sent un peu la testostérone en fait
parce que on a l'impression que c'est
des candidats qui se déclarent et qui se
mettent face- à face là il y avait un
peu ça avec le match à éedard Philippe
et je me mets au niveau d'éventuellement
être parmi les candidats et et peu
importe ce que ça crée au sein de la
nuupes peu importe les dispersions que
ça crée parce que c'est vrai que la
nuupes là on se demande comment comment
elle perdure c'est comme une coquille
transparente et puis il y a les egoos
qui vivent là-dedans ça ça c'est un peu
triste de voir que ils tracent ce sillon
là tout seul seul en en travaillant son
ego d'une façon assez réussie parce que
c'est vrai que c'est une des
personnalités qui ressort à gauche mais
indépendamment de tout le reste donc ça
n'a pas vraiment de cohérence sur cette
espèce de de matrice qu'avait créé
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ouais alors justement
cette stratégie de de la nupes de la
gauche avec ou sans LFI ça se jouait
aussi au Sénat cet après-midi puisqu'il
y avait l'enjeu de l'élection à la
présidence du groupe socialiste au Sénat
Patrick canner pas vraiment fan de la
nupes on va dire ça comme ça face à
ériic kouche un proche d'Olivier fort le
premier secrétaire du PS c'est Patrick
canner qui l'emporte qui conserve son
poste on l'écoute j'ai senti un groupe
très uni il a voté il a tranché il me
redonne sa confiance vous imaginez bien
que pour moi c'est très important parce
que c'est aussi la reconnaissance d'un
travail de de 6 ans je suis arrivé le 23
janvier 2018 à la présidence du groupe
dans les condition extrêmement complexe
did Guillaume qui était Président le
groupe était au bord de de l'implosion
on pouvait même imaginer une forme de
cataclysme et de la multiplication de
petits groupes donc voilà on en est
sorti et maintenant on va pouvoir
compter sur le groupe socialiste un
groupe
puissant un groupe qui va travailler
avec nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale en lien bien sûr avec le Parti
socialiste tout ceci est de bon augure
pour l'avenir et je prendrai ma part et
on va écouter tout de suite la réaction
d'Éric kerou sénateur desand est moins
convaincu sur sur l'Union on va dire a
priori mes cègues préférit la continuité
à la volonté d'alternance que je portais
c'est tout ce que je peux constater je
pense que Patrick caner a intérêt à
prendre en considération l'ensemble des
composantes du groupe et je pense qu'on
peut y arriver Bastien François au-delà
de de de cette bataille pour le le poste
de président de du groupe socialiste ici
au au au Sénat l'une des leçons de cette
de ce scrutin c'est quand même la
question de la Gauche unie sans
LFI c'était l'une des questions qu'on se
posait avant d'avoir les résultats
finalement quelle leçons vous en
tirez-vous benah c'est dire que moi j'ai
un point de vue peut-être un peu
différent des commentaires qui sont
faits c'est dire j'ai toujours pensé que
l'anupes n'existait qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale et n'avait vocation à
n'exister qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
laanupess a été créée dans à la sortie
de l'élection présidentielle où les
communistes les écologistes les
socialistes avaient été ratiboisé au
premier tour et avec Mélenchon le
candidat de gauche qui resta enfin qui
était en tête en tout cas euh face un
mode de scrutin le mode de scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours avec une prime
d'acè enfin et cetera qui fait que si on
ne s'allie pas on n'est pas au second
tour avec
fi qui était en position d'imposer en
réalité ces arbitrages bon donc ok c'est
une alliance électorale c'est une
alliance électorale qui perdure quand
même à l'Assemblée nationale parce que
quoi qu'il arrive même s'il s'envoie des
noms d'oiseaux et cetera il travaillent
quand même le plus souvent en tout cas
il y en a certains qui travaillent entre
eux il y a un intergroupe il a il y a du
travail de coordinationou mais avec mais
avec une stratégie pardoninrom une
stratégie du conflit permanent c'est la
stratégie mélchon qui euh déborde sur
toutes les familles de la de la nup
c'est pas si simple notamment pour le
parti aussi des effets au sein de LFI
bien sûr mais dans la perspective des
autres élections prenons les les
européennes il n'a aucun intérêt
électoral à faire une liste unique de la
gauche on fait beaucoup plus de sièges
en faisant quatre listes bon euh et là
dans le cas dans le cas des sénatorial
il n'y avait aucun intérêt électoral à
Salier avec les fill parce que les fill
a très peu très peu de grand
alors il ils ont ils ont sorti un
communiqué dimancheir disant 10 sièges
de perdu parce que faute d'alliance je
sais pas comment mais ce qui est vrai
c'est qu'il y a eu des listes
dissidentes qui ont pris des voies à
gauche c'est sûr et la gauche a perdu
sans doute une dizaine de sièges bon oui
mais le communf c'est l'inverse si on
avait été tous ensemble a si c'est pas
sûr justement parce que c'est pas
évident que les les électeurs les grands
électeurs et voter pour des candidats et
les filles à un certain n endroit donc
en réalité il y a quelque chose de tout
bêtement de l'intérêt électoral ou
électoraliste cet intérêt il est immense
il a été
immense pour les dernières législatives
dans le contexte de la
prèsprésidentielle à venir à mon avis il
y a ça a plus du tout de sens alors
justement c'est ça c'est ça la question
parce que là le le le spectacle alors
peut-être que c'est notre prisme de
journaliste je sais pas mais enfin en
tout cas le spectacle médiatique de
laanupes c'est la division ah c'est
c'est quasiment que ça depuis des Mo
c'est même pathétique he on a un niveau
de de de violence s'envoie du Jacques
Dorio à la figure quand même une des
plus proches député sopia Chikirou
proche de Jean-Luc Mélenchon accusant
Fabien Roussell d'être un héritier de
Jacques Dorot communiste devenu nazi
pendant la deuxème guerre mondiale on en
est à ce niveau de détestation mutuelle
parce que Fabien Roussel aurait empêché
Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'accéder au deuxième
tour c'est la haine recuite et cetera là
là sur caner kerouche au Sénat c'est la
perpétuation du congrès du PS non soldé
dans les través du Sénat c'est ça
l'histoire et donc vous avez là une
ligne non upes qui a
gagné cont contre Olivier fort premier
secrétaire du PS c'est très intéressant
pour la suite ça veut dire
qu'effectivement on a une majorité de
sénateurs PS qui veulent continuer à
croire en leur propre couleur sans
forcément aller chercher la bénédiction
de Jean-Luc mélonchon et de LFI et c'est
un tour de chauffe pour les municipales
parce qu'en fait les européennes s'il y
a pas la nupes c'est parce que chacun
veut se compter en 2026 au municipal et
parce que du score des européennes
dépendront les investitures au municip
les ver voudront garder leur mairie les
socialistes voudront reprendre du poil
de la bête donc en fait la nupes ne peut
revivre qu' législative suivante c'est
tout encore municipal en a un mode de
scrutin qui va aller dans le sens de
l'intérêt avoir plusieurs listes qui qui
se rassembleront pour un second tour
alorsigation redonner la parole à s
parce que il y a quand même vous l'avez
un tout petit peu évoqué tout à l'heure
mais je vrais qu'on qu'on se concentre
làdessus il y a une
thématique qui pourrait
porter des personnalités de gauche qui
qui émerge pas seulement sur les réseaux
sociaux les médias sociaux mais qui est
omniprésente c'est le pouvoir
d'achat absolument euh le le pouvoir
d'achat avec une sorte de montée en
puissance dans d'une forme de
ressentiment qu' sent sur les réseaux
sociaux euh et qui est une montée en
puissance pour le moment qui est assez
inexorable ce sont les prix alimentaires
ce sont les les prix de l'énergie bien
sûr de l'électricité du gazoil enfin
pardon des carburants et et ça ce sont
des sujets sur lesquels pour le moment
en tout cas on a assez peu de leaders
qui s s en Paris et El Goose pourquoi la
gauche n'y arrive pas sur ces thème-là
sur ces thème là mais parce que elle est
déjà empêtrée dans ses propres querelles
de nupes pas nupes il y a ce problème là
après il y a des points de des points de
convergence qui peuvent revenir très
vite hein si vous dites super profit là
vous allez avoir euh des coalitions
possibles même au-delà de la gauche mais
vous êtes d'accord pour dire que ça
c'est une période qui devrait qui
pourrait être favorable à une offensive
de de ses partis de gauche pour
récupérer un électorat qu'elle a perdu
notamment mais passante elle a perd dans
la la la curelle interne et parce que
aujourd'hui la gauche est beaucoup plus
identifiée par les électeurs sur les
sujets sociétaux beaucoup plus que sur
les sujets économiqu et sociaux et ça
explique d'ailleurs une bonne partie de
l'indifférence du désintérêt des des des
sympathisants de gauche pour les
élections quand je voyais un de mes
confrères qui avait fait un sondage sur
les les sénatoriales et on voyait que
les électeurs qui s'intéressait le moins
au sénatorial c'était les électeurs
socialistes qui normalement sont plutôt
ferru de politique par rapport aux
autres et donc quand Éric et rouge
disait on est peut-être en sous-régime
il faudrait faire quelque chose de cette
puissance quand même qu'on a au Sénat
làdessus il a raison on peut pas lui
donner tort c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment
il faudrait qu'il puisse être de nouveau
identifié sur des sujets qui normalement
sont des très bons sujets pour la
gaucheie bah il y en a un qui qui est
plutôt une qui est allé directement sur
ces sujetsl et qui a pris de l'avance il
me semble sur un sujet qui va revenir
sur le devant de la scène en 2027 le
pouvoir d'achat c'est Marine Le Pen
quand même elle a fait cette percée
c'est plutôt elle même si ça se
reconnaît pas peut-être dans les réseaux
sociaux on sait qu'elle a pe ch longemp
elle a elle a viré un petit peu les
fondamentaux on sait qu'ils sont là et
c'est porté par ERC Zemour donc elle a
pas besoin d'en rajouter beaucoup elle
est sur les pouvoirs d'achat et elle est
aussi sur cette classe populaire classe
moyenne que tout le monde est en train
de se disputer et que tout le monde va
se disputer à la présidentielle on a vu
Gérald amanin monter là-dessus on a vu
Édouard Philippe aussi commencé à monter
là-dessus elle elle a pris déjà
plusieurs pas d'avance et alors la nupes
les socialistes ils sont complètement à
la ramasse ils sont pas du tout sur ces
sujets là c'est vrai qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus sur des sujets sociétaux
on en est resté au violence policière
alors que la population a fa et demande
des efforts pour contrer l'inflation
mais c'est pas beaucoup plus simple pour
le gouvernement ben François on pourrait
même dire qu'il navigue à la godille
hein sur cette question les ventes à
perte les ventes à pertes de carburant
bon ça a ét une grosse pourisabeth borne
d'ailleurs au début de l'émission quand
vous disiez que c'était une rentrée un
peu tranquille je pensais d'ailleurs à
ça oui c'est-à-dire qu'il y a quand même
quelque chose qui monte là on parlait de
ressentiment ça va peut-être arriver
dans la colère il y a quand même quelque
chose qui est très difficile parce que
le gouvernement ne sait pas répondre bon
je je enfin moi j'ai pas d'idée
particulière pour aider le gouvernement
mais mais on voit bien qu' première
réponse elle a coûté 8 milliards de il
s'agissait de faire une Rone pour tout
le monde bon donc maintenant il a pas
pour tout le monde avec des effets de
seuil il y a il y a toute une série de
de voilà ils tentent ils essayent il il
essayent régler les problèmes avec des
mots il créent d'autres mots même M1 x
hein bon je a non mais c'est vrai ils
sont vraiment à la ramasse le
gouvernement av avait parié pas pas
parié hein c'était sur des projections
d'inflation qui seraiit plus favorable
en cette fin d'année donc il est
rattrapé par la réalité de l'inflation
et avec des solutions improvisées qui
finissent évidemment notre boudas on l'a
vu sur la la la la vente à perte du du
du carburant et et donc vous avez là
maintenant un sujet qui va monter c'est
celui qui est encore sous les radars
mais vous allez en parler c'est le
logement mur du logement qui est le
principal poste de dépense des Français
parle de bombe sociale de bombe sociale
à
retardement rentr étudiante je crois que
ça pas encore commencé partout mais là
aussi vous allez voir mais mais avec
avec une difficulté énorme pour le
gouvernement c'est qu'il s'est mis une
ligne rouge c'est qu'on touche pas on
augmente pas les impôts et et là il va
présenter un projet de budget où il a
annoncé des sommes absolument
gigantesques en tout cas pour les
questions de transition écologique donc
voilà il y a il y a une contradiction
quand même à un moment entre un état
protecteur et un état qui limite la sa
ressource fiscale et ça s'ils en sortent
pas voilà ils sont ils sont les main
liés ils sont ils sont obligés de Kander
à la grande distribution au marché en
réalité ils sont obligés de kemander au
marché
bienveillant et on commence à entendre
effectivement ou à lire des voix de de
commentateurs et économistes ou ou
politic qui disent la hax impôts elle
arrivera de toute façon même si Emmanuel
Macron fait pour l'instant effectivement
une ligne rouge à ne pas franchir il y a
le principe de réalité qui va qui
devrait le rattraper vous avez évoqué la
question de la la planification
écologique justement euh Émilie on va en
parler tout de suite avec vous on
connaît enfin le le programme du
gouvernement oui ça aurait été un petit
peu long hein 14 mois de réflexion
plusieurs report ça aurait été difficile
aussi pour le président parce que cet
Emmanuel Macron a découvert le
réchauffement climatique hein pour ses
vœux 2023 début 2023 euh ou encore
dimanche soir il nous disait qu'il
s'accrochait je le cite à cette bagnole
euh que j'adore hein c'est ces mots euh
mais ça y est le président a fait le
point sur ses ambitions en matière
d'écologie alors dites-nous tout les
détails il a trouvé son mootjo sur
l'écologie ça sera une écologie à la
française et finalement pourquoi pas on
sait que nous les Françaises et les
Français on fait toujours les choses
assez différemment que ça soit les
retraites la protection sociale le
chômage donc pourquoi pas l'idée
d'envisager une transition écologique à
la française même si ça sonne un peu
comme un concept publicitaire ça semble
pas complètement idiot allez on rentre
dans le qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière
cette expression c'est surtout une
écologie à la Macron je vous explique en
fait c'est une transition qui consiste
pas forcément à revoir nos comportements
de consommation et nos modes de
production ou bien à la marge mais
plutôt de continuer à produire et à
consommer à fond le tout pour que notre
compétitivité et notre attractivité
brille toujours autant au plan européen
et au plan international une écologie
créatrice de valeur économique c'est ce
qu'a dit et redit Emmanuel Macron hier
soir quand il présentait la
planification écologique on l'écoute
c'est une écologie qui crée de la valeur
économique et qui s'appuie sur une
stratégie industrielle c'est ça qui y a
derrière ce plan et sur lequel il faut
ici insister donc vous le voyez sur
l'ensemble de ce spectre on a
véritablement une écologie qui crée de
la valeur économique je pourrais parler
aussi de la stratégie agricole qui est
la nôre de la stratégie forêt biomasse
et cetera et cetera l'autre élément de
principe c'est que nous voulons une
écologie
compétitive et c'est un point clé si
nous voulons être souverain si nous
voulons créer de la valeur euh
économique et bien on doit avoir des
solutions décarbonées qui sont
pleinement compétitives donc si on n pas
compris hein il faut vraiment allier
écologie et économie ou compétitivité
plutôt l'idée elle est tout à fait
louable il s'agit d'un côté de
développer des filières industrielles
comme les pompes à chaleur ou bien les
véhicules électriques qui feront briller
les couleurs de la France et de l'autre
inciter les citoyens à passer à ces
modes de chauffage ou ces modes de
transport plus vertueux on sent
d'ailleurs beaucoup de prudence hein
pour ce président qui avait été
fortement secoué par le mouvement des
gilets jaunes je vous rappelle l'origine
de gilets jaune c'était l'augmentation
de la taxe carburant on sent bien que là
on est passé du bâton à la carrotte
est-ce que c'est cohérent avec le
programme économique on va dire en
général de de du chef deétat
complètement cohérent à la politique
économique qu'Emmanuel Macron lance
depuis 2017 plutôt favorable à la
croissance économique aux entreprises au
renforcement de l'attractivité de la
France alors après est-ce que ça sera
efficace est-ce que c'est réaliste on
sait par exemple qu'à l'heure actuelle
on produit très peu de véhicules
électrique français bon peut-être que ça
changera est-ce que ça sera suffisant
aussi pour attraper notre retard en
matière de transition écologique on sera
finalement au fur à mesure ce plan il a
au moins le mérite enfin d'exister et
d'acter les premiers pas dans ce domaine
parce que bon c'est vrai qu'il faut
l'avouer parce que en matière de
transition écologique on est à peu près
tous logés à la même enseigne
c'est-à-dire obligé d'apprendre en
marchant voilà et on va tous apprendre
dans les prochaines semaines à faire le
tri nos déchets alimentaires notamment
je RA que ça va rentrer en vigueur au 1
janvier je pasû que toutes les
municipalités soient prêtes bref ça
pourra être un bon thème de débat il y a
go qu'est-ce qui a guidé Emmanuel Macron
pour définir cette boussole écologique
d'après vous déjà la planification
promesse de campagne discours de
Marseille avril 2022 mon quinquen sera
éc écologique ou ne sera pas il il
reprend la planification le terme en
tout cas et la la le concept à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui voulait faire la
planification écologique 1 an après plus
d'un an après c'est une réalité il y a
un un secrétariat qui a bossé pendant 15
mois qui sur les graphiques on pas le
tétrrice de ce qu'il faut faire ou pas
histogramme par histogramme secteur par
secteur donc là il a la quantité
deom économisé qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire donc chaque secteur c'est un
travail assez monumental inédit il faut
le dire la France peut dire cocorico sur
on a un tableau de bord du changement
unique et nous on le maintenant il faut
le faire et là et là oùir ob moi ce qui
m'a surpris dans sa boussole c'est que
j'ai l'impression qu'il présuppose que
les Français sont trop sensibles aux
arguments du RN de la droite ou de
l'extrême droite disant c'est une
écologie punitive attention vous allez
faire trop d'effort vous en pouvez plus
vous avez à la casquette de l'écologie
il présuppose il boxe face à quelque
chose de virtuel à mon sens il a vu en
Allemagne l'extrême droite montée il
voit au Pays-Bas des mouvements
d'agriculteurs très féroces le parti PBB
qui peut faire un grosse SC législative
il voit en grand en réaction à une une
réforme agrare très verte hein c'est ai
pour ça et donc il est il regarde autour
il voit que attention ça peut être des
foyers de contestation populiste très
fort donc je fais une écologie
raisonnable mais moi ce qui me surprend
c'est que il y a il y a quelques mois il
nous a embarqué dans la sobriété il nous
a dit la fin de l'abondance et en 6 mois
les Français ont compris le message on a
baissé 10 % la consommation de gaz
etélectricité donc on est capable de le
faire et je je trouve que son écologie
là qui est en mode raisonnable
l'écologie du sérieux et cetera ne dit
pas toute la vérité de l'effort qu'il va
falloir faire et de la sobri qu' va
falloir avoir ditriété mesurée donc je
pense qu'il cache la vérité des prix et
à la fin attention au boomerang parce
que on n pas idiot on sait que l'effort
est colossal à faire et que il pourrait
embarquer les Français un peu plus un
peu plus que dans que dans l' B François
c'était un papier très intéressant de
Cécile cornulet dans les échos ce matin
qui disait une écologie qui pense à Le
Pen ça rejoint un peu votre argum sauf
que Leen elle n'a pas d'écologie
aujourd'hui donc il box face à un ennemi
virtuellu son oui est-ce qu'il cherche
aussi à vider un
peu le le le catalogue de Marine Le Pen
d'un certain nombre d'arguments vous
voyez ce que je veux dire avec cette
planification oui sans doute mais je
pense que c'est l'écologie de de de
d'Emmanuel Macron d'avant déjà c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est sa culture
économique c'est c'est son rapport au
monde et cetera c'est il parle de
planification mais la planification
c'était pas du tout ce qu'on a entendu
je même la planification à la française
hein pas la pas la soviétique c'était
quand même quelque chose de plus
beaucoup plus structur beaucoup plus
contraignant beaucoup plus construit
dans la concertation entre les
différentes forces économiques et
sociales c'est pas du c'est l'écologie
vous dites c'est raisonnable non mais je
comend ce mot
c'estécologie cure elle n'est pas très
raisonnable en réalité elle estelle est
pas très sérieuse parce que je veux dire
c'est pas là on est en train de dire des
choses qui sont fausses tous les tous
les scénaris de laadem et cetera nous
disent qu'il faut qu'on baisse 30 % de
notre consommation bon baisser 30 % de
notre consommation ça veut dire adopter
changer ça veut dire changer la société
oui mais donc est-ce que ça veut dire
forcément des sacrifices difficilement
supportable par les Français notamment
ces millions de Français il y en a
certainement beaucoup qui nous regardent
qui ont pas d'autre choix que de prendre
leur voiture pour aller travailler ou
emmener les enfants à l'école c'est
aussi à eux qu'Emmanuel Macron s'adresse
hier bien sûr mais à ce moment-là la
réponse ça serait la justice
sociale là c'est la réponse c'est le
marché ou là c'est la réponse on va
produire plus on va produire mieux on va
produire français bon euh il dirait oui
ça va avoir des coûts mais mais l'État
français va protéger ceux qui euh et ca
on parle de voiture électrique mais
personne ne peut se payer ses voitures
même avec des bonus même avec des
leasings à 100 € non mais un leasing à
100 € par mois ça va durer 20 ans pour
se payer une voiture les intentions
d'achat de voiture électrique ont
fortement baissé depuis 10 ans c'estàd
oui oui enfin il y a d'ailleurs tout le
marché on fera un débat sur le marché du
bio pour de l'agriculture bio c'est
pareil c'est un coup d'arr
les les pompes à chaleur par exemple oui
une pompe à chaleur c'est entre 10 et
20000 € plus avant pour que ça soit
efficace faut faire l'isolation de de de
son de son logement quelques dizaines de
de milliers d'euros qui va pouvoir se le
payer alors il dit ah on va aider on va
aider avec argent puisqu'on va pas
bouger on peut pas avoir de nouvelles
ressources budgétaires et on est on est
quelque chose qui enfin il y a une
contradiction interne dans ce discours
on revient à à cette question d'une
équation quasi impossible merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participer à à ce
débat je vous dis à bientôt sur
l'antenne de public scénar